hey what's going on youtube it's cameron
with motion science uh how's everyone
doing
on this fine day
how is everyone doing on this fine day
uh for those of you who don't know me my
name is cameron i've been a motion
designer for over 20 years now 20 years
plus experience
working after effects and a little bit
of cinema 4d just enough to
make me dangerous uh for 13 years i was
a freelancer
uh remote freelancer before remote
freelancing was a thing
i had the opportunity to work for a lot
of awesome studios like digital kitchen
prologue films
lots of awesome clients like disney mtv
nbc
sony xbox the list goes on and on and on
enough about me uh today we're talking
about
what is cinema 4d
and why should you use it
what is cinema 4d and why should you use
it uh but before
i get into that i want to hear from you
um i want to hear from you and know
do you use cinema 4d in your workflow
and um you know for the longest time i
was learning that people didn't
understand they didn't know that cinema
4d lite was included with after effects
and maybe some of you still don't know
that uh kind of blew my mind that people
didn't know that so it's been it's been
going on for years where they've been
releasing cinema 4d lights with after
effects
so if you do use cinema 4d i want to
know do you use the full version
or to use the light version that is
included in after effects
so do you use cinema 4d in your workflow
and which version do you use the full
version or the light version it doesn't
really matter you know what version of
cinema 4d you're on
i just want to know
what you're using
also while you're answering that in the
chat box
i want to let you know i also have a
free workshop
over at motionscience.tv
where i show you the seven secrets to
cinematic motion design it's actually
motion science dot tv
slash
workshop motion science dot tv slash
workshop i'm going to show you seven
secrets to cinematic
motion design
these are seven tips tricks and concepts
that behind
a lot of pro level motion design
plus i give you access to a special
offer
that you won't find anywhere else at the
end so please check it out if you
haven't already done so
dot tv a backslash workshop
and one last thing i want to mention
before i read your chats here i'm
looking at them coming in
i want to mention that i am having a
huge black friday sale this friday
um i am
i've put out a system um that's
it's being released for black friday
at this time
only
uh if you're interested in it it's
called the motion science mastery system
i'm sorry the motion design mastery
system i always call it the motion so
there's too much motion in these words
the motion design mastery system
for black friday i'm offering it for
sixty percent off what is it it's my
system that i put together that i think
every motion designer should have
it starts with after effects one two and
three
you then go into stylecraft
and then it finishes off with cinema 4d
quick start
and it comes with some awesome bonuses
like
a private community
a color in motion design course that
goes super deep into color and motion
design like it's amazing
the sci-fi screen graphics course which
is my most popular course i've ever
created
it's not available publicly
and the fourth bonus is 25 professional
luts and i hear it a lot like oh
everyone's including lutz and they're
you know to give away or whatever but
i'm telling you these were lots created
by an adobe
certified photographer
who
does amazing work and he put these
together specifically for motion science
so
that's what is the 60 off the motion
design mastery system it'll be this
friday if you're
not interested in that
i'm going to have 40 off everything else
in on the site so
every uh digital product is forty
percent off includes stylecraft ae
academy one two and three cinema 40
quick start all the texture packs all
the workshops
freelance effect
i think that's it so
awesome sale
don't miss out it's gonna be amazing
uh we did this last year except we
didn't have this the
the system in place the motion design
mastery system
um and um i'm really excited about
having that out now so this is a system
i've been like debating like should i
put this together as one system and yes
this is what you need if you want to get
up and running quickly in
motion design
check out the motion design mastery
system
okay
reading through some comments here
eon blue getting into cinema 40 was what
really helped launch my career as a
motion designer that's awesome
that's awesome
um
sajad
right it's the john is ready okay
awesome i am tears john uh anda from
transylvania what's up
uh luke starkiller what's going on luke
good to see you here man
um
daniel 28 years plus yes
long time 22 years
uh good times jc high camera release
always excited to watch these lives hope
everything is good really enjoying
starcraft so far awesome
i hear that from everyone everyone loves
starcraft i'm proud of that course
[Music]
luke just started diving into light
thanks to stylecraft but really want to
spend 2022 getting into it that's that's
awesome
that's a good goal to have luke
daniel is using light
nick is using the full version
e on blue studio
never really good because i do literally
everything really design okay
uh sajad which course
where can i find this course can you
share the site it's motionscience.tv i'm
not sure which course you're looking for
uh if someone donates to you two million
dollars we make your courses for free i
mean i already do a ton of stuff for
free
check out the youtube channel
lots of free content lots of awesome
content and lots of stuff coming up i
mean lots of just like i put out so much
free stuff
hey devx what's going on
sought craft gave me a taste of 740 when
i finished the course i want to try the
cinema 4d course as i really would like
to improve cinematic lighting of a model
yeah there's a lot of really awesome
lighting stuff
techniques and tips and tricks in that
course
i learned a lot from it myself
awesome okay
uh thank you william i appreciate that
you are the man i appreciate that
i appreciate that i try to give as much
as i can right try to give back as much
as i can
um
doing what i can do
uh sajad wishing for a good deal you're
gonna get a good deal this friday it's a
black friday sale this friday
um
check it out
oh good times lauren hey lauren what's
going on
i need to check out your color piece i
saw that posted i need to check that out
i still haven't checked it out i will
get to it i promise today
okay let's jump into some 40s um so for
those of you who are here that already
use cinema 4d um this may be kind of
basic knowledge to you
um
some of you in stylecraft you're going
to see some of the same techniques i've
taught there here
but this is more for people who have who
don't really understand what cinema 4d
can do
and the power of it
so let's jump over here let me switch
over here
but enough i just want to show you
really quick this is cinema 4d now it
doesn't really matter what version of
cinema 4d you're on um i know some
designers get really wrapped up in that
it's honestly it's not that important as
long as you have a
you know like i don't know 18
and beyond version 18 and beyond i think
they're up to version 24 25 at this
point
i mean there's so much you can do with
it um beyond 18 i mean it starts getting
very specific and things you can do like
with fluid dynamics and things like that
so if that's what you're wanting to get
into you probably want to get the newest
version
but for me i use older versions i don't
really focus too much on having the
newest best version but this is it and
i'm not going to jump into everything it
can do but it's a it's a 3d program
right it's just it's a basic 3d program
it's not a basic there's so much you can
do with it
from creating you know objects and basic
objects like you can see like cubes and
and text and and i mean everything
there's so much
you can do with cinema 4d
the possibilities are endless so the
thing about using cinema 4d
uh with after effects is that within
after effects we can only do very basic
3d right like we can extrude some text
we can use very basic
extrusions basically we can make some
cubes things like that um in the after
effects academy volume 3 course that we
have
ryan goes into some of the the 3d
capabilities of after effects but it is
limited at the end of the day it's
limited and that's why we have cinema 4d
where so we can create more
3d
beyond what after effects can do so i
like to use it
just as a
as a supplement to after effects right
now i have motion designer friends that
are very heavy in the cinema 4d one of
them being shannon wilkerson uh he's the
one who created the cinema 40 quick
start course
and he uses cinema 4d more
in the forefront for a lot of his
projects and then he uses after effects
to kind of finish them off to apply
effects to color correct them uh to add
typography things like that
so you can go either way you can go
cinema 4d heavy finishing in after
effects or you can start in after
effects bring in cinema 4d elements
and finish in after effects again so
that's kind of the approach i take and
um
[Music]
i'm going to quit this
and let's get this moved over here so
here i am inside of after effects
and it's really easy to work with
cinema 4d within after effects so
all we have to do is we create a new
project and it's really important
that you pay attention to your settings
like if i want to work at 24 frames a
second
versus 30 that's typically what i do
anymore because working with 3d
24 frames a second is less frames in a
full second
of rendering right so if you think about
if you're working in 3d because 3d does
take a lot longer to render versus after
effects
so the less frames we have to work with
ultimately the better off we are so you
want to be very
um aware of that when working with 3d so
i'm going to make
a shorter
composition here let's make it maybe
let's do four seconds we'll do four
seconds long
um 24 frames per second 1920 by 1080
click ok
and then we're down here in our timeline
and we're gonna go up here to layer new
and if you go down here all the way to
the bottom it's max on cinema 4d file so
i'm going to click that
and what it's going to say is hey we
need to we need to name this so we're
going to call this i did a test earlier
called shadows so we'll just call it
shadows
we'll do shadows test
and we're going to click save and what
it's going to do when i click save is
it's going to open up cinema 4d lite now
i happen to have cinema 40 light version
24. your version may be different it
doesn't matter like i said um they all
basically do the same thing right like
the interface
may look different
that's okay maybe you don't have this
pop-up in your version that's okay this
pop-up's a newer thing that they have
now i don't want to click new if i click
new it's going to get rid of my shadows
test.c4d that we can see here so i'm
just going to go ahead and close this
window
and you can see we do have a cinema 4d
file here called shadows test.cinema4d
just like we started so
um like i said there's there's so much
you can do with cinema 4d and i'm just
going to touch on
one a couple different aspects of it
okay we're not going to go into modeling
and all that kind of stuff
but let's say that we want to create
some 3d text with some some interesting
lighting
and
um you know we just want to make it kind
of cool looking versus what we can do in
after effects
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
go up to create here
and i'm going to go to spleen
and i'm going to find a text spleen and
it's right here i'm going to click ok or
just click on it it's going to load up a
text plane here okay now
again i'm moving these windows out of
the way you guys can't see these windows
it has to do with my live stream but it
kind of gets in the way
and there's a lot going on here so you
can see we've got text right we've got
text split up here in the window we've
got text here
down here in our object properties we
have text and i can highlight that
and i can just type in whatever word i
want so i'm going to type in shadows and
click outside that box and you can see
there's a spleen here for shadows
okay now below this i can change
the font
of course i clicked on it it's probably
going to load up all the fonts which i
should probably shouldn't have done that
and there we go i'm just going to keep
it here regular
but um you can change to any type face
you want
uh let's do alignment let's go to middle
and you can see our middle point here
this is 0 0 zero in our cinema 4d world
and i just want the text to be center
aligned so that's great
you can adjust things like height which
is basically just how big it is
let's go ahead and change this back to
200.
we can adjust you know spacing and
things like that for vertical spacing if
we had two lines of type
uh horizontal spacing
you know there's just a lot you can do
here and you can really customize your
text
but now if i go to um to render this
actually let's just render it here
within the window
you can see it's black right there's
nothing there and that's because this
text is just a spleen
excuse me so we need to give this text
some extrusion some depth to it
so we go up here to extrusion and we
pick extrude and we drop our spleen into
our extrude and immediately boom we've
got some extrusion here right now i'm
not a huge fan of like real big
extrusions and maybe you saw my recent
youtube video where i
uh recreate the netflix titles from
project blue book if you haven't seen
that yet definitely check it out because
it shows you some possibilities of what
you can do just within after effects
with 3d type
um and i use a real heavy extrusion for
that but i had to do it because i was
creating this super long shadow system
yadda yadda go check out that video if
you haven't seen it yet so anyways we've
got our extrusion here and what i can do
is click on our extrusion and i can see
that it's set to an offset of a hundred
so i could take it like 50 it's just
going to make that text a little bit
less deep right it's not so deep
so that's cool um so now if we render it
again
we can see boom there it is the reason
we can see this is because by default
cinema 4d always has a hidden light
within our scene um and that's just
because when you add things you're
seeing you want to be able to see what's
going on without you know if you don't
happen to have lights in here so there's
always a hidden light you can't touch
the light you can't control the light
you can turn it off
if you don't want that but that gets a
little bit deeper into preferences and
things like that
so
if i want to be able to see this at all
times what i can do is i can go up here
to
interactive render region i'm going to
click that and you can see i've got this
box here right
and this box is rendering just what i
have inside of it so if i make this box
smaller i can just see this area
if i
make the box
large like this i can see the entire
scene right so now it's always rendering
and excuse me i've got a little slider
here on the right side
if i take this slider down
it makes it less you know it renders
faster
but it's less quality whereas if i take
the slider up
it's a higher quality but it may take a
little bit longer to render just you
know because we have one set of text
here it doesn't take a long time because
it's really you know it's just very
basic geometry when we start adding more
and more geometry to the scene
more objects and lights and things like
that the render time starts to go up
right so
that looks pretty cool so far very basic
but that's okay
i'm gonna go up to create again and
let's go here to primitive and let's
find
let's use a plane okay
so there's our plane and it's just a
flat plane right there's no depth to it
i'll go up here to my rotate tool i'm
gonna hold down my shift
on my keyboard so i can snap it by five
degree increments here
and go up to 90 degrees
then we've got a background i can drag
this little handle here and i can extend
my background out maybe something like
that
i can extend the top of it maybe like
that
um certainly kind of cool right
um a little trick here something i like
to do for every cinema 4d project i work
in
is i like to go into the render settings
and i like to use an effect called
ambient occlusion okay so i'm going to
click that and i want you to watch what
happens here between the letters in the
background or within the letters you're
going to see some shadows
start to appear
see how that's coming through there
this is a really easy way to create
what's called ambient occlusion as the
name says um but it creates some very
realistic shadows where where edges meet
or polygons are meeting with their edges
it creates a lot of realism right so if
you turn it off
that's what it looks like basic 3d but
just turning it on adds some real
interest visual interest to the render
immediately
now you can comment back in here and you
can adjust some of these settings
but honestly i never really play around
with these settings it's it's always
very it works for me right like if if
you want to adjust like how dark the
shadows are
or not how dark they are um that's where
you can come in here and kind of use
this stuff
but for the most part right out of the
box this works it's great i love it so
starting to look kind of cool
next thing let's do let's add a camera
so we'll go up here to camera and we'll
click here
and there's our camera and the camera by
default whenever you add it it's going
to
go to the position the rotation
everything that we were currently in
with our perspective right so we were at
this angle
already so the camera's now at this
angle
so what i can do
i can click on this camera click on
coordinates and i'm sure i'm going
faster if you're not familiar with
cinema 4d at all but that's okay you can
come back and watch any time
i can zero out these these parameters
here okay
i'm going to leave z
as it is
you can see there's nothing changing
here because we need to look through the
camera and that's happens by clicking
this little button right here now we're
looking through the camera and we're
obviously looking over here which is
kind of weird and that's because we have
some angles
set up within our camera so we're going
to zero out zero and then tab zero
again and now we're looking straight on
to the shadow and you can see my render
is starting to kind of slow down a
little bit right we're closer to the the
text
we've got some ambient occlusion
happening here
um
excuse me so
it starts to slow down a little bit if i
want to you know decrease the quality i
can take it back down about halfway here
and it's going to go a little bit faster
so now i've got these controls up here
right and this is how you can control
how you move around in your scene so i'm
going to use my i'm going to click and
hold and kind of pull back here
maybe i want to rotate a little bit
like so
you know maybe i don't know maybe
something like this kind of move it
around
maybe pull back a little bit
um yeah looks okay
kind of a basic start now if i click on
this white box again i'm going to go out
of my camera and i'm right back to that
same perspective view now i can move
this perspective view around
and i can see my camera you can see it
down here
let's go ahead and turn off interactive
render region for a second
you can see my camera down here
you can kind of see what's going on with
the scene you can also see here it's a
lot easier to kind of navigate the 3d
world versus after effects right
now any of you guys who follow my
tutorials
you know that i use the after effects
camera the 3d camera all the time for 99
of all my scenes i'm using the 3d camera
and um
the biggest thing i noticed with a lot
of people who come in
to my courses
they struggle at first with using the 3d
camera because it's a little bit
wonky
navigating 3d space in after effects and
hopefully one day that will change but
it's you know since the 3d camera's been
out it's always been kind of wonky so i
don't know that's going to change much
but it's a lot easier to navigate the 3d
space within cinema 4d like you can see
here
now i can also click this button beside
here
and i can go into a for view mode which
i see here so this is my perspective
excuse me
this is my top view i can zoom in and
out of my top view and that's my my type
here
this is a right view and this is a front
view so at any time if i want to come to
a four views or three views or two views
i can do that and i can see
very easily what's going on in my scene
so i'm going to click here and go back
to my perspective
and let's actually go back to our camera
and next let's add a light right we have
our lights here and we're going to use a
spotlight
and
you can see now things are starting to
look weird like right like we can't
really see
the type
because we've added a light so we added
that light
um the the default light tends to turn
off when we do that so here's our render
and you can see like okay this is this
is why there's a default light built
into cinema 4d
uh so that we can see things when we
start working so i'm going to click here
and drag and just hold down my shift
button to go oh 90 degrees so now our
light's pointing down
click take my move to i'm going to move
my light up here right and so you can
start to see some things happening here
right
um still a little bit weird
let's go back into our four views and
let's take our z handle and bring it
forward
because right now what's happening is
that light is a lot of that light is
hitting behind the wall here
so let's like drag it forward here
maybe something like that like something
kind of dramatic
i can click and drag here and expand
my spotlight
so i can see a lot more of the word
and that's starting to look kind of
interesting
i like that
let me get a drink really quick
i'll drink my coconut water
sorry about that
okay
so uh you can see here with the light we
can add multiple lights if we want to um
it just depends we're just gonna do like
a kind of a basic light here
um something really cool we can um do
now is if we want we can add textures to
this right so
basically this the scene there's no
textures on it right it's very i'm going
to save this actually
yes save um what we can do is come come
down here to create and we can create a
new we'll do a standard material keep it
pretty basic
we're going to take that material we're
going to drag it on top of our extrude
and now i can double click this material
and i can kind of play around with some
things you can see reflectances on
colors on
we can do things like transparency right
let's turn transparency on you're going
to see okay all of a sudden this this
text got really
kind of funky looking because it's
transparency text right so there's all
these different types of presets here
for transparency
we can play around with just the uh the
brightness of the transparency like
maybe turn it down a little bit
pretty fun to play around with it i'm
going to turn transparency off we can go
into color here we can play around with
color
give our text some some interesting
color like that
um
let's go ahead and go back in our four
views
maybe give a little bit more light in
the front
uh not too bad not too bad let's make
this even more interesting at this point
okay so what can we do to make this even
more interesting what we can do is we
can take our light
and we can go into
um let's go into general and let's cast
some shadows and we're going to cast
some shadow maps soft
look at that look at those crazy shadows
happening there
let's go back into our four views
and if i can get it to load here
trying to make something kind of moody
that's kind of
nice it's all about those little subtle
details
and next thing we're gonna do is we're
going to go into
our back into our light here and let's
add some color to our light
oh now it's getting even more moody
and let's also go into something called
visible light here let's add some
volumetric light
and right off the top it's not doing
anything
but you're going to see here in my
right view when i added volumetric it
added this kind of curved
display down here
if i turn it back off to none you can
see it's just a flat
plane there we'll go back to volumetric
and we're going to go ahead and drag
this guy down
and what we're doing here is creating
some atmosphere
that's gonna happen here
now you can start to seeing it see it
happen there
yeah that's looking pretty cool
and you're going to see here i'll show
you the difference
you know we can
do a lot with this we can
let's form the quality a little bit so
you can see like it's almost like
there's some fog here right there's some
atmosphere so this is width and this is
without
you see that there
turn back on
i like to use a lot of volume
in my lights
so that's looking pretty cool
make this light a little bit
yeah no it's quite so saturated
something like that um and then all we
have to do now is we can just save
and this project's saved and if i jump
back into after effects this is what's
really cool
you can see my cinema 4d project is here
inside of after effects
now by default we're seeing the draft
mode of that image and if i change it to
current
it's going to show us a full render
of this uh cinema 4d renderer and it
might take a second here it's full res
so there we go
excuse me
so i'm gonna change this to half rows
um now what we could do to you know take
this even further is we could actually
add like a
camera inside of after effects
so we can go to layer a new camera
we'll do a onenote sure we'll click ok
and
you can see that it's not the camera
doesn't do anything and what we have to
do here is we have to go into our
cinema4d file
and under effects is cineware
we have to tell it hey we want to use a
comp camera we can use a centered camera
or a comp camera i usually tend to go to
centered comp camera
and there we go now we're using our
after effects camera
so what we can do is i can use the tools
inside of after effects the camera
controls i can zoom in on it
and it's gonna you know
it's not gonna be real time let's change
it back to
viewport draft a little bit faster that
way so you can kind of see it more of a
real time here and let's go ahead and
set a p for position
and we'll do some
rotation
come here at the end of our timeline
and maybe we'll do something
i don't know we'll do something just
basic
and maybe we'll
kind of start it over here it's pretty
actually um
it's here
so you can see now
i built this basic scene in
cinema 4d
but then within after effects i can
control the camera and all that
i can you know render this at full
resolution
if i want to go back to
current
and it's going to take a little bit
longer to render the preview at this
point
um but i can i can also the advantage of
this is now i can actually you know come
in here and really start fine-tuning the
image
um versus just keeping everything in
cinema 4d so if i wanted to create like
effects i could do like adjustment
layers
you know i love you know lighting
effects like glows and things like that
so
of course it's checking for updates
you know i mean we could do all types of
things here we could
do effects and things like that i mean
we could do very basic things like um i
mean whatever you get the idea you can
just you can come in here and you can
start tweaking it and
making it really come alive within after
effects so this is a great example of
how i like to use cinema 4d i like to
use it for basic things like text
sometimes like if i'm doing a product
product rendering
i'm going to build it in cinema 4d bring
it here in after effects like this
kind of separate it composite it that's
a whole nother video that we'll talk
about sometime about you know
compositing different layers within
cinema 4 of cinema 4d within after
effects so you can control all of the
different layers like shadows and
transparencies and diffusion and all
that kind of stuff so um
yeah that's what i got for you that's
just a little taste of like what cinema
4d can do
there's just so many
by incorporating by using cinema 4d
with after effects you're opening up a
whole new world of possibilities with
your motion design right
yes after effects can do two and a half
d which is the flat
2d planes in 3d space which i'm a huge
fan of
yes after effects can do
basic typography uh extrusions basic
like shape extrusions
um but
using cinema 4d
we can go a whole lot further you know
like i could actually come in and
really texture the word shadows
do like some type of crazy texture on
there you can't do that in after effects
i could texture each letter if i wanted
to with some crazy texture i could
texture the background if i wanted to
there's just a lot you can do with it um
something else that's just kind of cool
though
here's here's a half rez runner playing
back
you know we could animate the light
that could be kind of cool but something
else is you can also incorporate um
you know 2d layers in after effects
with this too so we'll do i don't know
just the word test
soon to be a big fan of the word test
lately
um
make it a 3d layer
make it a lot smaller
you know and i'm just showing you see
how that that text layer now
it moves with the 3d layers right
so that's because it's using an after
effects camera it's everything's being
composited within after effects so
we can
merge 2d and 3d within after effects
very easily using cinema 4d in after
effects
i'll let this preview
and there you go
so that's what i got guys that is what i
got let me um
switch this back
to me
uh let's see what we got here
uh eonblue cameron your products course
really helped me out but since then i've
bought i've brought a lot of that photo
separation work instead of a 4d and i'm
getting a lot of work because of
adapting that skill set to cinema 4d
amazing that's awesome
have you seen i'm sure you unders you
know this stuff but um
we have two or we have a workshop
at motion science that will be on sale
for black friday
um cinema 4d projection mapping
uh ryan put it together and it's really
awesome it's it's a lot of those
parallax techniques it's like taking a
photograph
projecting it onto geometry and then
moving within it and
you know creating 3d worlds it's it's
really awesome
hey mark hello from atlanta what's going
on atlanta
uh nissa what's better for cinema 40 or
blender for motion design so okay so i
get asked this a lot
um
i mean i'm going to say cinema 4d and
the reason i say that is because
cinema 4d is made to work in a
production pipeline
it's got support
it's production ready
blender
last i heard does not have support
and is not
you know production ready so
any
uh post house who's working with 3d is
going to
be hesitant to use blender
for a large scale production
um because
when you run into issues in a production
you're on a set timeline
and time is of the essence and if you
run into some big technical problem and
you have no technical support from the
company that creates that product
that's a big big problem
so blender is amazing for like
you know
one person using it
maybe you know making a short film
maybe a couple buddies using it um but
in terms of like if you wanted to go
professional
um i would you know i
i would stick with cinema 4d
so that's more of like the tool that is
used that's very
accepted
across the board for production studios
[Music]
so i mean to me they're both really
powerful programs they could both create
some amazing visuals
so but yeah i mean like mark said cinema
4d all the way from from row graph
all right guys
uh any other questions i can answer for
you uh regarding cinema 4d before i wrap
this one up
um really enjoyed
uh showing you guys cinema 4d like i
said this is really basic stuff
but the idea here is just to kind of
show you what is cinema 4d
what can you do with it i mean
there's just so much you can do with it
so much like it just creates
these endless worlds of possibilities
for what you can create in mograph
so
uh yeah we all know houdini is the dad
of all 3d software yeah i mean
yeah i mean it's you know
it's got a it's got support
it is used in production houses but
houdini's a different beast right
a good friend of mine uses
cinema 4d
uh and then houdini on the side
for certain jobs so it just depends on
the job but it is it's growing in
popularity for sure but it's a different
it's more procedural
um what is the good faster alternative
to global illumination in cinema 4d um
a faster gpu
is what i would say i mean i'm not an
expert in gi rendering
but the faster your gpu is
the faster your global illumination is
going to be and you know these
third-party renderers
could do all that kind of stuff pretty
fast
octane redshift which is used more in
industry for lighting effects
um
you know for lighting effects i don't
know specifically i have friends that
swear by octane and friends that swear
by redshift
my ones who use
3d and more of a production pipeline um
tend to use redshift more and that was
even before
maxon purchased them
um they swear that that's more of where
it's going to go
is redshift um i don't use any
third-party renderers personally i am
interested in using the octane renderer
that comes for the m1 processor for the
mac because i use m the m1 chips
m2 chips and one max
so i'm curious to see where that goes
um but in terms of lighting effects i
mean
you know octane has a very specific look
to it
uh when it blends the bloom
but i think that too many people use
that and it gets kind of overused
so yeah
mark recently purchased after effects
coming one through three loving every
minute of it best and most professional
training by far thank you mark i
appreciate that comment that's a that's
a nice comment
everything i create inside of motion
science i i
toil over it i try to make it the
absolute best
product it can be
and that's my mission to just keep
creating amazing courses and and
training for all of you guys to uh learn
motion design so
i'm gonna wrap this one up thank you
everyone for being here today i really
appreciate you guys
guys and gals and
like i said if you haven't checked out
my free workshop
do check that out it's motionscience.tv
free workshop
7 secrets to cinematic motion design
it's awesome
and also check out the black friday sale
happening
this friday
60 off the motion design mastery system
as well as 40 off everything else in the
motion science store
uh guys thanks for being here today and
i look forward to seeing you on the next
live
hopefully coming up next week we'll see
ya